bonsoir à tout ce nous sommes le
mercredi à 15 juin vous regardez le 7 8
le journal merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition nous allons
revenir sur votre actualité locale avec
nos invités
mais également les journalistes de la
rédaction tout de suite on commence avec
des titres retour sur l'attentât de
magnanville aujourd'hui une cérémonie
hommage a eu lieu en présence de bernard
cazeneuve ministre de l'intérieur ainsi
que le préfet des yvelines pour rendre
hommage au couple de fonctionnaires
assassiné par l'art aussi à bâle à lundi
soir faut-il démontré pour savoir
travailler - est-ce vivre mieux ce sont
quelques-uns des sujets de l'épreuve du
baccalauréat de philosophie sur lesquels
les élèves de terminale ont planché ce
matin nous sommes allés recueillir les
premiers sentiments des élèves du lycée
de villa roi de guyancourt et après une
dizaine d'années d'immobilisme l'hôpital
jean martin charcot de plaisir se
renouvelle à la culture et notamment le
street art sont au coeur du nouveau
projet de l'établissement
pour nous en parler ce soir notre invité
en plateau jacques eberhard directeur du
centre hospitalier et pour ouvrir ce
journal nous revenons sur l'attentât de
magnanville dans les yvelines une minute
de silence a été observée au ministère
de l'intérieur et dans tous les
commissariats de france en hommage au
policier à sa femme fonctionnaire du
ministère de l'intérieur tués lundi soir
à magnanville 300 policiers de
mantes-la-jolie et des mureaux les deux
commissariats ou travailler des victimes
étaient rassemblés pour une cérémonie
commune dans l'établissement muriautin
en présence notamment de pompiers de
gendarmes de magistrats du procureur des
familles des victimes
je vous propose d'écouter serge morvan
préfet des yvelines il a lu une lettre
de bernard cazeneuve le ministre de
l'intérieur il ya certainement de la
colère de là à dire qu'il ya malaise non
parce que nous avons évidemment
confiance à nos policiers très bon
policier dans ces deux commissariats
très bons policiers partout certainement
en france mais moi je parle de ce que je
connais ici
venez y sommes malheureux femme et un de
plus à ce stade sont dans cet état
d'esprit cdc les parents de policiers il
savait connaissent évidemment la
difficulté et la grandeur du métier de
policier et les sacrifices
évidemment très douloureux voilà
l'esprit la minute de silence des forces
de l'ordre s'est déroulée à huis clos
dans la cour du commissariat en
extérieur des anonymes avaient tenu à
être présents pour rendre aussi hommage
au commandant de police et à sa compagne
tuée lundi soir à leur domicile je vous
propose de les écouter
je suis extrêmement choquée puisqu'on a
atteint on a fait atteinte aux valeurs
de la république et surtout parce que je
suis extrêmement en colère
extrêmement en colère parce que je pense
qu'on paye quand même des années de
laxisme et qu'il est temps que nos
politiques que fasse quelque chose pour
nous protéger mais je disais à double
titre parce que mon fils est et au
commissariat de mantes la jolie en poste
donc collègues de jessica l'eau dans la
tête ils sont plus à l'abri quoi je
pense surtout à cet enfant de trois ans
qui se retrouvent orphelins c'est très
triste
ça pourrait arriver à n'importe qui j'ai
l'impression qu'on est plus en sécurité
ici et le conseil des institutions
musulmanes adhésives in a tenu à réagir
à cette attente a dans un communiqué il
condamne fermement cet acte odieux et
présente ses condoléances les plus
sincères aux familles des victimes à
leurs collègues ainsi qu'à tous les
policiers de france
le simi formule son soutien à la police
nationale une des institutions
institutions pardon constituant les
devoirs régaliens de l'état qui garantit
un bien commun des plus précieux la paix
civile
il déclare qu aujourd'hui plus que
jamais il s'agit de protéger cette paix
civile gravement menacée c'est le
meilleur moyen de rendre hommage à la
mémoire de ce couple qui a voué sa vie à
ce noble dessein tout autre sujet plus
léger à présent c'était le jour j pour
les dix-sept 1589 élèves il y devine wa
de terminale et zélé les épreuves du
baccalauréat 2016 ont débuté aujourd'hui
avec quatre heures de philosophie quatre
heures pour plancher sur des sujets
comme nos convictions morales sont elles
fondées sur l'expérience
le désir est il par nature illimité ou
encore travailler - est-ce vivre mieux
cette année plus de 690 me les élèves de
terminale passer leurs examens
nous sommes allés prendre la température
devant laisser de villa roi de
guyancourt un reportage signé michael et
demi d'euros 7h45 au lycée de villa roi
guyancourt plus de 300 élèves attendent
ce mercredi 15 juin avec la boule au
ventre avant de passer les épreuves de
philosophie
premier rendez-vous du baccalauréat 2016
assez stressé voilà mais bon on va
essayer de le faire ça bien ça je suis
détendu mais en fait j'ai peur de tomber
sur un truc où j'ai pas du tout
d'inspiration donc là tout de suite ça
va mais on verra quand je serai devant
ma copie ça risque d'être difficile de
supporter la pression
une fois la convocation présenter à
l'entrée les élèves sont répartis dans
vingt classes il ne reste plus qu'à
croiser les doigts pour tomber sur son
sujet de prédilection
cette année les élèves de es ont planché
pendant quatre heures sur l'histoire et
sur le thème de la liberté
les littéraires sur la politique et le
réel dans la filière scientifique il
fallait philosopher sur le désir ou le
rapport entre la technique et la nature
là c'est tout frais donc je sais pas
vraiment vers le résultat mais je sais
pas trop je préfère pas m'avancer je
suis plutôt mitigé je pense pas être
sujet mais après
je pense pas un pet et laissera pas
alors qu'est ce qu'on entend par une
bonne hauteur et que ça c'est une
question limite philosophique une bonne
note ça pourrait être entre
ah les 13 et 15 e j'espère la voir mais
c'est c'est très peu probable parce que
ça ça demande énormément de travail et
même si je l'ait peut-être fournis je
sais pas si je pourrais l'avoir une
nouvelle dose de stress est programmée
pour ce jeudi là 200 7e édition du
baccalauréat se poursuivra demain par
les épreuves d'histoire géographie pour
les filières générales au total les
yvelines compte 17 1589 inscrits cette
année au bac c'est une autre source de
stress pour peut-être les futurs
bacheliers vous savez la grève dans les
transports continue en lien avec la
contestation contre le projet de loi
travail de la ministre myriam el khomri
ainsi la sncf a décidé de reconduire un
dispositif datant de 2014 pour aider les
candidats au bac empruntant le train
atteindre leur centre d'examen sur fond
de perturbations la subsistantes au
niveau national ces 600 trains circulent
en période de pointe à mercredi qui
seront identifiés sncf spécial examen et
qui bénéficient d'une priorité de
circulation en cas de perturbations
selon la sncf si un des trains rencontre
une difficulté la sncf rentrer heures en
contact avec les académies pour
permettre aux candidats d' entamer
l'examen jusqu'à une heure après son
début théorique un décalage identique
étant accordée à la fin cela se
déroulera pour les autres épreuves
également et parlons grèves et
mobilisations c'est le quinzième jour de
grève aujourd'hui à l'appel de la cgt et
sud rail les deux syndicats toujours
opposé à loix travailler à l'accord sur
le temps de travail restent sur leurs
positions
le mouvement continue donc pour la cgt
cheminots de trappes qui a reçu ce matin
les cgt infos comme air france sip et
goodyear lors d'une assemblée générale
les représentants sont venus remettre un
chèque de solidarité de 15000 euros au
syndicat yvelinois les militants ont
besoin de fonds pour financer leur grève
au niveau national une caisse de
solidarité a donc été mise en place le
23 mai pour pouvoir à faire des dons la
cagnotte atteint désormais plus de
400000 euros à trappes
les militants ont récolté en tout dix
mille euros je vous propose de les
écouter cet argent il vient de tout
les deux retraités de jeunes de salariés
qui n'ont pas forcément plus faire grève
reconductible qui se sentent solidaires
du mouvement et qui ont souhaité par ce
geste concret soutenir les grévistes en
grève reconductible ça te permettra de
filer un coup de pouce pour arrondir un
peu des fins de mois qui s'annoncent
difficiles pour tous les grévistes sans
exception chaque syndicat
chaque structure décide comment elle
organise l'aide
sachant qu'ils signent une charte qu'on
a mise au point et qui consiste à dire
que tout le monde doit être et des
syndiqués non syndiqués etc et qui
normalement doit enfin oblige la
structure à être transparents sur
l'utilisation des fonds et passons à
présent à l'économie et l'entreprenariat
local comme chaque année l'association
réseau entreprendre en yvin organisé sa
soirée annuelle au palais des congrès à
versailles l'événement a eu lieu hier
mardi soir c'était l'occasion de
récompenser 13 lauréats yvelinois et
créateurs entreprises qui ont été
accompagnés par le réseau entreprendre
fanny bourdillon étaient sur place
chaque année au mois de juin le réseau
entreprendre en yvelines fait ces
lauréats à versailles en 2015 ils sont
treize à être soutenu et financé par
l'association
parmi eux l'institut supérieur de
l'environnement basée à trappes
grâce au réseau entreprendre on
bénéficie d'un accompagnement
personnalisé
on bénéficie d'un soutien financier puis
parallèlement ça nous permet pour nous
d'encre et plus fortement l'école dans
son réseau local des entreprises des
yvelines
ce qui est très important pour garantir
une bonne insertion professionnelle de
nos jeunes tous les lauréats yvelinois
reçoivent un prêt d'honneur pour cette
école le montant s'élève à 40 mille
euros de quoi se développer et surtout
créer de l'emploi
objectif premier c'est d'accompagner la
création d'emplois et donc nous
accompagnons des entreprises qui
s'engagent à créer 5 à 10 emplois au
minimum dans les deux à trois ans et
donc là la fête de lauréats et chaque
année une grande opportunité de mettre à
l'honneur ces gens qui ont été méritants
et qui ont mérité d'être labellisé par
des entreprises c'est nicolas beytout le
parrain de la promotion 2015 créateur du
journal l'opinion
il est venu rencontrer chaque lauréat
c'est quelqu'un qui effectivement a créé
son entreprise donc c'est à la fois
effectivement un journaliste économique
et en même temps un entrepreneur donc il
connaît le monde de l'entreprise et
surtout en 2016 quoi on connaît les
difficultés depuis la création de réseau
entreprendre en yvelines en 2009
l'association a accompagné une centaine
d'entreprises et les résultats sont
concluants
trois ans après 91 % de ces entreprises
sont pérennes et voudront une page santé
à présent à l'occasion de la journée
nationale de la lutte contre la
maltraitance le conseil départemental et
l'association gérontologique et des
yvelines ont présenté le dispositif
d'accompagnement pour les personnes
âgées
l'objectif de cette association basée à
magnanville est créée il ya 30 ans est
simple prévenir et lutter contre toutes
les formes de maltraitance envers les
adultes les plus vulnérables williams
elle pour ce reportage dans ses bureaux
de l'association gérontologique des
yvelines
les deux psychologues qui travaillent
répondent à environ 250 appels chaque
année la nature et les causes de ces
appels maltraitances physiques
psychologiques ou encore financière sur
des personnes âgées
la première partie du travail celle
écoute qui est très importante puisqu'il
s'agit de qualifier la maltraitance de
voir les différents interlocuteurs
intervenants professionnels qui peuvent
sont susceptibles d'être déjà dans la
situation et après il s'agit de mettre
la personne si c'est un particulier en
lien avec le professionnel de terrain ce
professionnel ira ensuite à la rencontre
de la victime supposée pour mettre en
action les outils des travailleurs
sociaux
un dispositif baptisé m avait 78 qui
s'inscrit dans la lutte contre la
maltraitance des adultes vulnérables les
appels sur la plateforme yvelines 192 en
176 en 2015 nous sommes le troisième
département de france qui remet qui
remonte au temps dans 55 % des cas le
maltraitance est un proche
c'est à dire les enfants le conjoint ou
le reste de la famille une augmentation
des violences en institution a été
constaté par l'association ces deux
dernières années une campagne de
sensibilisation est lancée par le
département en direction du grand public
c'est trop tabou il faut il faut que les
gens sachent qu'il faut dénoncer ces
situations on peut être maltraitant
anvers
anvers tous est ce un parent proche sans
vouloir par négligence et donc c'est
aussi important d'être sensibilisés à
une façon d'être maltraitant qui n'est
pas dont on n'a pas conscience
c'est la cinquième année consécutive que
le contrat entre l'association et le
département est renouvelée pour une aide
d'un budget de 180 mille euros et nous
continuons à parler santé dans notre
entretien et notamment du renouveau de
l'hôpital jean martin charcot l'hôpital
implantée à plaisir va subir un lifting
pour nous en parler ce soir avec noof
jacques bérard directeur de
l'établissement merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation et devenir donc y
répondre à nos questions alors l'hôpital
jean martin charcot a été construit au
début des années 60 les quatre pavillons
actuelle installés dans le centre
psychiatrique voix totalement réhabilité
et un bâtiment flambant neuf de 14 8
mètres carrés devraient sortir de terre
en mars 2018 le projet était attendue
depuis plus de dix ans par les passions
pourquoi ton difficulté pourquoi tant
d'attentes avant que ce projet revois je
reconnaisse de saison montpellier alors
c'est un projet très ancien puisque le
programme remonte à 10 298 la
construction 2006 2007 et il ya eu des
des malfaçons de
en maîtrise d'ouvragé publique de
planches et de passerelles qui sont
faites des ponts couverts donc qui ont
complètement bloqué le chantier en
décembre 2007 le chantilly a dans un
premier temps était mal réparé en 2009
puis plusieurs architectes se sont
succédé et enfin nous arrivons à
redémarrer nous avons renouvelé
complètement la maîtrise d'oeuvre
et les entreprises sur ce projet alors
le coût global de l'opération s'élève à
peu près à 25 millions d'euros
c'est une opération qui est financée et
par l'hôpital et grâce notamment à
l'aide de la rs alors logistiquement
comment cela va s'organiser
alors on va rénover le
ce bâtiment qui est achevée à 85% ce
parce que c'est compliqué en deux phases
une première phase où on va refaire cinq
services cliniques de 25 lits et une
deuxième phase où on fera les abords les
voiries autour et une unité spécifique
pour les hôtes histoire alors la ligne
du projet et notamment centrée autour de
la culture
il ya une grande fresque qui a été
dévoilée donc c'était le 20 mai si je ne
me trompe pas pourquoi justement avoir
décidé de mettre la culture au centre de
ce nouveau projet absolument alors ça
c'est une volonté au départ d'un des
ingénieurs de src vinci qui a eu cette
idée là de faire une opération un peu
street art art éphémère
donc nous avons et nous avons
immédiatement dit oui c'est une
opération qui était d'ailleurs financée
par exercer vinci et nous sommes en
tournée vers la ville de plaisir aussi
qui a été enthousiaste notamment madame
cohen berger donc nous avons décidé de
redémarrer ce chantier parce qu'on avait
cinq passerelle à démolir en faisant
peindre une de ces passerelles par un
artiste s'appelle arnaud puig et donc
nous allons nous faisons une opération
art éphémère certes nous allons
récupérer des morceaux de fresque qu'il
a fait notamment appel aussi à des
enfants ce projet l'interné on a associé
des enfants effectivement et du quartier
du val ibuki est un quartier de plaisir
qui est tout proche de l'hôpital jean
martin charcot
mais également des enfants de
pédopsychiatrie qui sont soignés dans un
hôpital de jour à saint cyr puisque
notre site pédopsychiatrique et à saint
cyr l'école
vous avez justement décidé de mettre la
culture est ce que finalement l'hôpital
et la culture
ça va ensemble ça peut donner un
meilleur romieu meilleur ami
l'environnement alors psychiatrie
culture c'est un excellent mariage
puisque la psychiatrie par définition
est une discipline ouverte sur
l'individu le développement personnel et
sur la ville sur la société
donc nous avons déjà nous avions déjà
avant cette opération un certain nombre
de partenariats culturels notamment avec
le château de versailles en
pédopsychiatrie mais également avec le
musée maurice denis à saint germain en
laye une développant ses partenaires
culturels vont maintenant avec du street
art et nous avons encore de nombreux
projets donc nous allons sommes en train
de rédiger un projet culture à l'hôpital
sur qui couvrent à la fois jean martin
charcot et l' hôpital gérontologique
médico-social qui dans la même direction
qu'est ce que ça change parce que ce
serait pour les patients pour les plus
jeunes je pense que c'est vraiment faim
dans un environnement où ils se sentent
mieux mais pour les personnes peut-être
plus âgé il ya vraiment une autre
dynamique
en instaurant voilà la culture sans
gravité alors c'est encore plus
important pour les personnes âgées et
les handicapés puisque il y en a
beaucoup sur l'hôpital gérontologique et
médico sociale qui en face de charcot
puisque cela passe quelques fois dix
quinze vingt trente 30 ans de leur vie à
l'hôpital et donc voit plutôt dans un
établissement c'est un hôpital c'est un
établissement médico social et donc ils
ont besoin d'avoir accès à la culture la
citoyenneté
donc c'est extrêmement important pour
eux pour les malades qui reste un peu
moins longtemps comme ceux de charcot
chasse au sarko restent en moyenne entre
20 et 30 jours pas plus dans le séjour
c'est également important mais c'est
surtout dans les structures c'est
également dans les deux structures
ambulatoires qui sont on a 21 structures
ambulatoires sur l'ensemble du divine
que ces malades peut aussi avoir accès à
la culture il ya des gens qui font du
théâtre des arts plastiques
c'est extrêmement important pour le
développement de la personnalité c'est
pas une obligation mais on le propose
systématiquement aux malades qui le
souhaitent
il va y avoir d'autres projets un petit
peu street art comme ça au sein de
l'hôpital quand elle va se construire
c'est possible en tout cas il ya des
dans le partenariat avec l'école d'art
d'aix en provence sur et la
pédopsychiatrie de saint cyr il ya des
projets qui se rapproche un peu de ça il
est possible qu'on développe un peu le
street art mais en tout cas on va
essayer d'avoir une conception de la
culture très ouverte et pas uniquement
tournés vers le classique voilà même si
c'est même si la fresque de tarnos puits
qui s'est inspiré dans les vendée
l'enlèvement des sabines mais elle a été
bien dans l'évent de sabine a subi un
certain lifting on va dire alors c est
un chantier de grande ampleur voilà qui
se met en place il y avait voilà un
besoin pour le territoire est ce que
justement il y avait peut-être une
pénurie on attendait avec impatience le
renouveau cet hôpital
il ya un besoin certain ne serait-ce
qu'en confort hôtelier puisque le
confort hôtelier actuellement d
pour les malades qui sont hospitalisés
chaque coup n'est pas acceptable
notamment en termes de salle de bains et
aurait même si eu des relations de fait
dont il y avait un besoin de confort
hôtelier
il a besoin de prise en charge des
patients aussi on charcot le plus gros
hôpital psychiatrique des yvelines juste
avant montesson et soit une 65% des des
malades mentaux du sud-yvelines donc qu'
il y avait un réel besoin en tout cas ne
seraient annoncées sur le plan hôtelier
pour le personnel hospitalier a besoin
d'adaptation justement par rapport
voilà ce nouvel hôpital il y aura un
gros travail d'adaptation puisque nous
passons de 6500 mètres carrés dédiés aux
soins à 14000 donc il y aura des temps
de déplacement assez long il ya une
grosse un gros travail qu'on a commencé
sur la logistique la fourniture du linge
de la cuite et de la nourriture etc
on retrouve une taille presque trop
grande d'ailleurs mais on était trop à
l'étroit maintenant on sera extrêmement
au large et donc on a besoin de gérer
tout ça y compris en terme financier
puisque c'était établissements on va
avoir un coût d'entretien important on
sait que l'on voit les chantiers ne
tiennent pas forcément alors délaisse à
ce dernier la sq mars 2018 ça vous
semble voilà plausible comme il est on
va dire 2018 puisqu'il ya toujours des
aléas en tout cas on appris avec eux snc
lavalin comme assistant maîtrise d
ouvrage et src vinci prend comme
entreprise on est maintenant bien
entouré il y aura certainement des aléas
je ne peux pas le cacher mais on vise
toujours 2018 toile très bien merci à
jacques bérard d'avoir accepté de
répondre à notre à nos questions et nous
prenons à présent la direction de
rambouillet nous refermons cette page
santé avec la berge owni la bergerie
nationale
elle a été créée par louis xiv est allé
célèbre pour ses moutons mérinos elle
fait un appel aux dons son colombier
nécessite une restauration urgente le
bâtiment emblématique est classé
monument historique depuis 1944
mais il est fermé au public depuis 1990
une situation qui a poussé la bergerie à
faire appel à la fondation du patrimoine
a vient afin que celle-ci lui vienne en
aide
fané bourdillon et sephora namani un
trou béant orne le plafond l'échelle et
cassé des chutes de plaques de plâtre
entoure le pigeonnier le symbole de la
ferme royal de rambouillet la fondation
du patrimoine lance une levée
fonds pour elle ce bâtiment a une
mémoire historique crucial parce que
c'est un élément emblématique de cette
ferme quand on a constitué cette ferme
au xviiie siècle fermes modèles voulue
par par louis saez on a fait des
bâtiments d'élevage d'exploitation mais
le pigeonnier qui était un élément non
seulement décoratif mais de pouvoir de
symboles du pouvoir et donc c'est assez
le symbole si vous voulez de
l'importance politique que pouvait avoir
cette ferme
trois cent mille euros une somme que la
fondation veut rassembler pour subvenir
aux besoins du bâtiment fermé au public
depuis la fin des années 90 les
dirigeants de la bergerie ont des
projets plein la tête pour ce colombier
une fois restauré ce pigeonnier va
d'abord être réouvert au public parce
que pour l'instant on peut pas l'ouvrir
au public il est pas en état ensuite on
espère pouvoir y faire des activités d
animation des événements culturels
on verra des expositions on peut faire
des expositions photos on peut faire des
expositions tables on peut également
faire une petite résidence d'artistes il
ya plein d'idées pour pour valoriser ce
monument une fois qu'il sera restaurée
au moins cinq mois de travaux seront
nécessaires une fois les fonds récoltés
ce qui ne devrait pas affecter les
visiteurs ni les pensionnaires de la
bergerie et sports à présent il n'y a
pas que le foot il est aussi
l'équitation à la proche des
championnats de france d'équitation en
juillet à lamotte beuvron les différents
centres équestres illinois se prépare
notamment le club de bois d'arcy qui
organisait dimanche dernier son
troisième concours de sauts d'obstacles
de l'année sephora namani et patrick
jacques de dixmude pour ce reportage
c'est sous l'oeil attentif de son coach
que les rc lens avec java 2,6 frérot sa
ponette sur le parcours de 12 obstacles
organisé dimanche dernier par le centre
équestre de bois d'arcy résultat qu'en
bon par contre malgré deux erreurs
j'ai l'impression qu'elle avait un petit
peu peur de la pluie mais ça allait mais
après c'est peut-être un peu de ma faute
si si elle a dérobé
j'ai pas assez mais des gens mais je
suis pas assez écarté maman j'aime bien
concourir et la dernière fois j'avais
raté mon parcours alors j'arrive à
rester sur ça ça fait partie du
du processus d'apprentissage 1 comme à
l'école faut qu'ils commencent par des
petits parcours faire des erreurs et
puis et puis essayer de pas les répéter
ce qui compte c'est d'apprendre quelque
chose et comme je dis aux élèves
on apprend plus quand on perd que quand
on gagne parmi les 60 partants dimanche
matin des cavaliers yvelinois de
différents clubs des amateurs qui
enchaînait un parcours de sauts
d'obstacles pour la première fois tout
comme des compétiteurs de club en élite
qui venait s'entraîner sur de gros
obstacles en prévision du championnat de
france de cet été nous avons fait ce
concours un petit peu pour
éventuellement donner des qualifications
à ce qui a manqué pour la motte beuvron
sont les championnats de france
et en plus pour clôturer un petit peu
l'année ça ça donne un but de travail
tout au long de l'année
il s'agissait du troisième concours de
sauts d'obstacles organisé cette année
par le centre équestre de bois d'arcy et
nous finissons à ce journal par une note
festive samedi la ville de man pas
célébrer sa traditionnelle fête au
village l'association de toiles en
battant a proposé de nombreuses
prestations aux habitants des jeux
étaient organisés pour les enfants la
journée et une animation musicale avec
soirée danse ont clôturé l'événement
l'occasion pour les norvégiens de se
rassembler et de profil et profiter de
cette journée conviviale à côté on
trouve des spectacles au moment du des
jeux pour les enfants un restaurant qui
est très attractif et très bons donc que
demander de plus on y trouve un petit
peu de joie et puis les gens qui se
rencontrent qui se retrouve c'est une
ambiance de village tout simplement on
se croirait dans un village très loin de
paris il n'y a pas qu'à mort pas qu'on
sait s'amuser ce week-end à saint cyr
l'école a eu lieu la traditionnelle fête
foraine de la ville pendant trois jours
les saint cyriens ont pu profiter en
famille les divers stands comme les
dopants auto tamponneuses pardon encore
la pêche aux canards une installation
moins conséquente cette année
habituellement installés sur la zone
industrielle au renard les forains ont
dû installer leurs équipements sur le
parking de la gare et côté on apporte
quand même un petit peu de joie autour
de nous les gens sont contents
ça évite de penser à leurs petits tracas
quotidiens et de pouvoir s'évader le
temps de quelques heures sur la fête
on est une petite dizaine à une petite
dizaine mais habituellement la fête de
saint cyr ça représentait une trentaine
de manèges quoi il ya de moins en moins
d'espacé rien et adaptée pour nous et ça
c'est regrettable
c'est une bonne idée maintenant je
comprends qu'il faut aussi de l'espace
ça n'a pas toujours bonne réputation
mais je pense que dans les dans les
villes un petit peu comme ça c'est à
l'école c'est je pense que ça permet de
proposer une activité différente à la
population c'est pour longtemps qu'on
est là mais oui c'est divertissant donc
c'est intéressant c'est la fin de cette
édition je vous remercie de nous avoir
suivis rester avec nous tout de suite
vous retrouvez sephora namani pour un
nouveau numéro de votre magazine
culturel kiosque il sera question
notamment de la fête de la musique avec
tous les rendez vous à ne pas manquer
pour cette date quant à moi je vous
retrouve demain pour une nouvelle
édition du journal je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée